Adam thank you I am joined by Baroness
Michio the crossbench peer whose
amendment was passed by 307 votes to 277
and a Conservative MP Michael Ellis
who's very critical of what's happened
in the Lord's tonight with the unelected
Lords defying the elected House of
Commons Baroness Mitra your amendment
really is all about further analysis
being done what do you expect to happen
now well I expect further analysis to be
perfectly honest what we've done today
is to say look hold on to this
regulation don't pass it today in this
unelected house leave it to the
government to think again and also to
the House of Commons the elected chamber
who are going to have an all-day debate
on Thursday and a vote on these issues
and we've left the thing open so now the
government will listen we took it to the
House of Commons and the conservative
majority Zeiss staff understand it has
disappeared on these issues now that the
conservative backbenchers really
understand better not completely none of
us do better the implications of these
regulations so eight conservative MPs
understand have put an end to the motion
for Thursday debate and of course the
majority is in 1336 not so you know this
is the Frank field motion that's backed
by conservatives like David Davies Zac
Goldsmith and so on can I just ask you
about this evening what is the
significance of the Labour motion
amendment being passed as well well the
labor amendment requires additional
spending on transitional arrangements I
don't think it's really for me to
comment on that I think it's a very very
powerful message that now goes to
the the government that this this house
yes the unelected house feels
passionately in representing the the
most vulnerable the poor's working
households in this country and of course
all stood up for working what I said
stand up for working people and yet here
they are pulling the rug from under
working people in obvious Michael Ellis
there you have it the House of Lords
according to Baroness Meacher is
standing up for working people well that
would be a first though John is that we
cannot have a situation where the
unelected house appears over rules the
democratically elected House of Commons
the House of Lords has resisted that
temptation for a hundred years they have
had that temptation placed in their path
on dozens of occasions over the last
century
on tonight's votes particularly I might
add on the Labour motion not the
crossbench motion but particularly on
the Labour motion it is a constitutional
outrage this clearly involves four and a
half four point four billion pounds
worth of public spending forget for a
moment the issue that is at stake in
terms of the the pinpoint precision of
the amendments the principle that the
House of Commons holds sway over
financial matters is a crucial one to
the functioning of our Constitution and
otherwise we have self-appointed people
in the House of Lords people who have
decided that they know better than the
democratic elected elected chamber
attempting to overrule the elected
chamber but they've resisted that for a
hundred years tonight they haven't so
what we expect now is that the
government will bring a motion back to
the House of Commons do you think the
government can get it through in the
comments because we know there are all
these conservative backbenchers who are
unhappy with what the government's
proposing which on the point is it's
already passed to the House of Commons I
DS got the cottage cheese or Commons now
isn't it it was passed by the House of
Commons when conservative back benches
so they just didn't understand what it
was all about
and the fact is as Jacob Riis monk says
Conservative MP the huh cigars deals
with these regulations very badly
actually they they're busy people they
don't have time to go through these
things indeed it's not for the House of
Lords to make that judgment it is an
impertinence if you like for the House
of Lords to say that the House of
Commons doesn't know what it's doing you
may not like it but it's happened well
of course of course it's happened but
the point that I'm making John is that
it is unprecedented that it is an
outrage to the Constitution this
statutory instrument only five have been
defeated in the past hundred years and
all five of those none of them involved
finance so we've got a situation where
the House of Lords says it knows better
than the House of Commons we hear lines
such as the MPs didn't really know what
they were doing and things of that sort
Jacob is a friend of mine but you can
find members of parliament on any party
who will say different things what has
happened is what counts is the the House
of Commons has passed this and now it
has been sent to the House of Lords and
they have rejected it they've decided to
defy convention and it should and
hopefully will have consequences for the
House of Lords but what appears to have
happened here is that despite the
arguments that you're making about the
Constitution the fact is the lords seem
to be reflecting public opinion we've
done polls at Sky News others have done
them and you heard Tory MPs speak out in
the debate in the House of Commons last
week well we have a general election
system in this country where a party of
government is elected in this case
that's happened less than six months ago
it isn't for the House of Lords to to
subvert that and to say that our opinion
today matters more than the
democratically elected members apartment
John MacDonald has just made the point
on Sky News that in fact it was not in
the manifesto this specific proposal and
both Mr Cameron and Michael Gove when he
was the Chief Whip denied that this was
going to happen
well the Salisbury Convention which goes
back to 1945 is the manifesto I'm not
sure people care about themselves well
but I don't care about how much money's
in their pockets in the run-up to
Christmas and
absolutely of course they do and the
reality is that the issue today is one
of finance the issue is one of finance
and since since the 17th century the
House of Lords has tacitly accepted that
they will not attempt to overrule the
House of Commons because as the
Americans said at the time of their
revolution no representation no taxation
without representation
Baroness Meteor what do you say through
what you've just heard you're shaking
your head
what's your this is a welfare reform
regulations maybe the government should
have put this major piece of regulation
into the budget in which case this house
would have just said it's nothing to do
with us they wanted to sneak it through
without proper debate because such
incidents don't get the level of debate
normally that other that legislation
does so this is what's happened so
probably the government made a big
mistake there but this has regularly
takes back issues to the House of
Commons our skin governments to think
again on welfare reform issues which
involve money and all sorts of other
issues and governments do think again
and sometimes they accept our
recommendations and our amendments
sometimes they toss it back to us and
many many times I've done it myself with
ministers if I'm really concerned about
government's making a mistake
I'll have meetings with ministers and a
good Minister will in fact compromise if
they can hear that actually the
arguments going forward are strong and
reasonable if we get into parliamentary
ping-pong which we might if no you can't
on sessions recorded that okay what you
can do what's the point it's a killing
motion no it's a fatal both no I'm sorry
it isn't well it was made very clear
behind and bounced back to the House of
Commons it is no it is not a fatal
motion according to our clerks who know
everything there is to know about
procedure in these places because of no
to knew everything there was to know no
that's far as the House of Commons the
clerks no mystery that what we've done
is to keep the statutory instrument
alive
to allow the chancellor of the exchequer
to think again and to amend that in his
own time if he chooses to do that and my
proposition is that what we are wanting
is the Chancellor to listen to the House
of Commons the elected house on Thursday
now that conservative backbenchers
former cabinet ministers who signed
after this relation assuming I sentence
I know it that they have signed up to
this motion for debate on Thursday
meaning there is no longer a
conservative majority on these issues
that is a massive story about so much it
is not right voted through the House of
Commons so you can't say it hasn't it
has when MPs didn't understand the
consequences got to blow the whistle for
full time I've got to blow the whistle
there was a tour of World Cup rugby
referees here in the central lobby a
short time ago I wish I wish I had a
whistle
as bad as me chairs just said the next
debate on this is in the Commons on
Thursday on a motion proposed by Frank
field and a rebel MP Stephen McPartland
David Davis Zac Goldsmith and others so
the next debate in Parliament on this is
on Thursday we've not heard the last of
this